okay huge night for you tonight in so
many ways first let's start with the
nominations four of those bad boys yeah
um you know for me
it's it's a night of magic a night of
Celebration but you know what tonight is
about is the celebration of hip-hop and
um you know I'm just honored to be kind
of in the eye of the storm like from
fruition to completion and that's what
tonight is we just had LL here on this
stage and in his words when we asked
about the tribute he said
it's just crazy it is and I couldn't say
the word he used but no I mean you know
what what I'm really grateful for is to
be of age like I was of age when hip-hop
came to us and it was like almost seeing
like a spaceship in the sky and now to
still be here like I you know you could
never tell eight-year-old me that I
might be part of curating something
really magical and it's like a family
reunion like just to sit there and watch
all these acts like
hug each other and really like build
each other up and you know because
oftentimes you know hip-hop is such a a
sport a competition
um and for people to just drop their
guard and be vulnerable it's it was
something beautiful to see so when
you're sitting down and you're thinking
about putting this together yeah the
first call you make is and then how do
you put that list together
um what I did was I made a I made a
mixtape you know I you know they kind of
have me around right before Christmas
so I was just racking my brain I wanted
I wanted to be all inclusive so my first
draft was like 27 minutes with over like
100 artists
and they laughed me out the office like
nah no do something normal like 12
minutes and I was like you know so
tonight is going to be a 14 minute
retrospective of some of the most
beautiful music ever created by the most
beautiful people
you know ever so
dying because when I was talking to Too
Short he was saying you know when he
started in the game they said rap was a
fad right so talk about hip-hop and how
it has yeah you know
enhance the culture tonight is literally
the day we've been waiting for if you
remember when hip-hop first got
nominated and there was like a protest
on the on the building because it wasn't
yeah you know and now we get a seat at
the table and that's the conversation we
had to have with each individual person
like don't be dismissive like this is no
this is real and you get we're getting a
seat at the table now can I ask you you
know you you've you've got I Too Short
said there was just west coast folks in
there I did see that DJ Jazzy Jeff was
part of it is Will part of it too uh
Prince part of it okay I'll I'll
let you all know he was literally
99.44 and
but they started uh shooting bad boys
for
um this week so he couldn't make
rehearsals but he agreed to he wanted to
be everyone wanted to be a part of
History this is more about people like
yo why can't I do it like I had to cut
so many people off
foreign